أعظم مجزرة اغتصاب عرفها التاريخ
، نتج عنها نصف مليون طفل ألماني
مجهول النسب
، تم تسجيل الأطفال بأسماء أمهاتهم لأول مرة في ألمانيا،
كان على النساء الرضوخ أو الرضوخ وليس هناك خيار بديل
، في بلاد هيتلر العظيم، امتهنت النساء وأهينة الكرامة،
وأذلت دولة عظيمة، بعد نهاية الحرب العالمية
انتهت عزة الألمان وانتهى غرورهم
، مالذي حدث يا ترى في ألمانيا،
وكيف غابت شمس الألمان
في ذلك الوقت؟،،،
(للقصة بقية)
تحكي إحدى الضحايا واسمها، كلارا مولر من ماغدبورغ،
فقالت إنها كانت تجر دراجتها المحملة بأغراضها
بعد أن تدمر بيتها عندما أوقفها جنود سوفييت
فطرحها أحدهم أرضا وكانت منهكة وتناوب الباقون على اغتصابها
وخلال الاعتداء مرت عدة سيارات لقوات الحلفاء
لكن لم يحاول أحد إنقاذها رغم بكائها وتوسلها
. وتمكنت حسب قولها من التحامل على نفسها للهروب
فأخبرت أمها بأن الدراجة قد سرقت واخفت عنها الاغتصاب
لأنها كانت تخجل مما حدث لها
ولم تتمكن من مواصلة صمتها بعد أن أدركت أنها حامل
وبمساعدة إحدى الممرضات
تمكنت من الإجهاض وما زالت حتى اليوم
تعاني من مشكلات نفسية.،،
وهنا بدأت نار الانتقام وما زرعه جنود هتلر بالأمس
بنساء أعدائه هاهي نساء ألمانيا تحصده اليوم،
وبعد أن هزمت ألمانيا في الحرب العالمية الثانية،
هاهي المستشفيات الألمانية تعج بالنساء
، لكن لماذا؟ فالنساء لسن جريحات في الحرب
ولا جئن لزيارة أزواجهن،
مئات آلاف النساء أصبحن حوامل،
وعشرات الآلف منهن جئن ليجهضن أطفالهن في المستشفيات،
فما الذي حدث؟...
خلال الأشهر القليلة التي تلت الحرب
ظهرت نتائج أفعال الروس بالنساء الألمانيات،
لقد حدث أكثر من مليون اعتداء
١٩٠ألفا من هذه الإعتداءات قام بها الجنود الأمريكان،
و٥٠ ألف اعتداء قام بها الفرنسيون
، و٤٥ألف اعتداء قام بها الجنود البريطانيون
، يالهذه الوحشية!،
وجاءت هذ الإعتداءات جلها  في اغتصاب الألمانيات،
ناهيك عن اعتداءات جنود الحلفاء،
والمصيبة الكبرى أن من ارتكب هذه الجرائم البشعة
هم من يصدعون رؤوسنا
بمحاضراتهم اليوم عن حقوق الإنسان،،،
وبينما جاء الروس ودخل معهم جيش الحلفاء
ليحرروا ألمانيا من النازيين بعد هزيمتهم في الحرب العالمية الثانية،
والحاصل أنهم ما جاءوا إلا ليذلوا النساء
ويهتكوا أعراضهن
ويسفكوا دماءهن ويعذبوهن أشد تعذيب،
فكانت المرأة الألمانية إن رفضت الاغتصاب
تموت حتما،
وإن تم اغتصابها فقد تموت كمدا وقهرا أو قد يقتلها الجنود للمتعة،
وهنا نقول أين كان أزواجهن وإخوتهن وآباؤهن؟ ،،
في ذلك الحين كان الرجال والمقاومون يقبعون في السجون،
وهنا .ظهرت بشاعة اعتداءات الجنود فكانوا يغتصبون
كل ما يمت للمرأة بصلة،
نعم لقد اغتصبوا النساء العجائز والشابات
وحتى الأطفال دون ال١٠ تعرضن للاغتصاب،
بل كانت بعض النساء تتعرض لأكثر من٧٠ عملية اغتصاب،
واغتصبوا الرجال والأولاد كذلك،
فاليوم يوجد في ألمانيا أكثر من ٥٠٠ ألف رجل وامرأة غير شرعيين،
وبعض النساء لازالت تبحث عن أباء أبنائهن إلى اليوم
وينشرن في الصحف والمجالات البريطانية والفرنسية والأمريكية والروسية
ليصلن لهم لكن دون جدوى،
فيما اختفت البعض منهن خوفا من العار الذي لحق بهن،
والبعض الآخر يزعمن أن آباء أطفالهن قد ماتوا،
ويذكر بعض الجنود هذه الحوادث بقولهم
لقد حاولنا إذلال الألمان بأي طريقة كانت
احتفالا بانتصارنا على الجيش النازي،
الجيش الأحمر جيش السوفييت ينتصر على جيش الألمان النازي،
لكنه لم يحتفل احتفال الأبطال بانتصاراتهم
بل ارتكب أبشع الجرائم بالنساء والأطفال والشيوخ،
ونتج عن جرائم الجيش الأحمر وحلفائه،
جيل من الأطفال مختلط الأجناس أطلق عليه اسم
«الأطفال السمر»
تبنتهم عائلات ألمانية كأجانب، فالقانون الألماني حتى عام 1948
كان يحظر زواج الألمانية من ملون، والمجتمع الألماني
كان مجتمعا محافظا، بعيدا عن الرذيلة،
كان هذا هو العيب الأسود الذي لن ينساه الألمان
وقد تناسته منظمات حقوق الإنسان،،
فهل ينتقم الألمان ممن فعل بهم هذا يوما ما؟